i'm telling you bro is it a v8 is it i
don't know
because i don't know engines like that i
don't know cars like because i ain't got
one
that's that's true i had i had a car
since 2007
2018. tell the truth i'm telling the
truth right now i'm telling my troops do
you want one last car i had was a 99
jeep wrangler
well talk about it what color it was uh
it was like a
uh like a dark blue purple type [ __ ]
kind of like the uh like it's like it's
a metallic kind of color yeah like
metallic conical it was a 99
yeah that [ __ ] was dope it was it was
off the chain that's when you had a car
this one i had a car i had one about two
years two years you missed it do i miss
having a car hell yeah
yeah cause i went to i went to uh i go
to sometimes i go to my homies house in
riverside
and yeah i caught an uber yesterday
homie was just like
showing me he's showing me some song
that little john made about tacos that i
didn't know exuberant driver did
yeah you can but you can select if you
want to talk or
music or whatever you can oh yeah but
most of the time they don't talk to me
i i prefer that yeah but you're in
someone else's car it'd be weird if i
just keep looking like i've never heard
the name chappelle before
that's what he said yeah nothing's worse
than where you're from
[Laughter]
pretend you're on the phone but like
would you say he's like
simon i did that i did that with the air
position i'm like i'm on the phone i had
the phone to my ear with the air pods in
my power through it
yeah he was like bro i got two i got two
conversations going yeah you know how
long the ride was to riverside an hour
it was with no traffic yeah it was
barely anything yeah what friend
is this you're taking an uber that's my
best friend oh it's your bestie
yeah yeah that makes sense yeah but i i
mean i would like to usually i catch the
train
there's a train that goes out there but
i mean i didn't uh i think i missed
yeah does your girl have a car yes she
does
oh my god oh there he is there he is
what's up
man come on what's up
yeah i didn't super good man what's up
um but yeah that's the home you man what
you guys do
uh watch project runway that's our [ __ ]
um
for an hour you would have copied i got
a couple of questions about let you
finish oh he's gay
oh okay it makes sense makes sense okay
oh is it tommy yeah
oh my i didn't know i didn't know okay
you got a
spectrum full of friends i do you got
like these bad
old cheerleader ladies then you got
these
them gay boys and then you got your
comic friends
yeah yeah yeah i do have and i got the
crust punks the krusty punks i
kick it with crusty punks yeah you got
ranged up mm-hmm
a lot of people don't have that [ __ ] i
was telling you you have range
yeah i hung out with some white people
the other day there he got rain
i got range just white people yeah
was it that one picture you saw the one
picture the dude looked like he was
the member of the bad boys what'd you
call them you called him lip biscuit
yeah yeah steve oh
what's up what's up brother thanks for
doing this man hell yeah
you look great brother thanks bro i
appreciate it man you too
you still uh staying away from the
animal meat is that what's going on yeah
i've been eating fish oh you started out
with fish yeah
you weren't doing fish for a while right
i was vegan for uh
for a long time and uh i don't know i
think uh
getting cats had something to do with it
how's that
we gotta [ __ ] feed your your cats
some kind of meat like the wet food yeah
i plus my dogs i feel like an [ __ ]
feeding my dog's vegan [ __ ] yeah they're
like why are we doing this
yeah like we just signed up for this
right so then
it's like all right well if i'm buying
[ __ ]
fish for the dogs and the cats like [ __ ]
it [ __ ]
yeah plus i just think it's good for me
so and you feel good on it
yeah i think it's good for me it's
better than all that [ __ ]
super processed [ __ ] fake [ __ ] yeah
that
uh you know i like that yeah was the
impossible stuff
that should sound delicious but it's
just cancer that's that's
terrible the beyond burgers are the kids
it is not healthy
really yeah it's so good i know they're
delicious well thank you
anything that tastes that good isn't
good for you they're they're
[ __ ] delicious but
read the ingredients you'll be horrified
there's so much stuff that goes into
them
well i i can't even remember because she
can't
even pronounce to me it's not good
everything's just right
hydrosodium like chlorine
sulfur yeah you know what i don't even
know what it is but it sounded like pork
yeah you don't want to touch it okay you
don't want to touch it now i don't even
eat red meat i don't you really
by the way did we start already because
this is great
man he was like
okay there's [ __ ] that sucks about it
and
and
and there's [ __ ] that rules like what
sucks is
we had started filming jackass four
right like a fourth movie which
i agree it makes no [ __ ] sense i'm
all for it
i mean actually like we got one week
into filming jackass four
and uh that's when the shutdown happened
yeah which is
a pisser it's also a blessing because
there are obvious question marks around
whether a bunch of [ __ ] 40 and in
some cases
50 you know john is knoxville 50
i will be soon i think he's 49. yeah
he's up there a couple of the other guys
have crossed 50.
i'm so foreign
firmly that the older you get the
funnier it is
i agree i don't know 100 i think at a
certain point it just gets kind of
tough to watch but but hey man i i don't
mind a bit
and and the one week that we were able
to film
uh the chemistry was there the [ __ ]
footage everything's worked out
fantastically so
we were able to put together enough
footage in that one week
for the question marks to be answered
where can we still do it
yeah can we see the chemistry still
there is it going to be does it still
work
is it just creepy
everyone's not doing this
whose idea was it to get back together
i'm sure knoxville
everybody else has just been clamoring
for it my position was like hey man i
never stopped doing that [ __ ] anyway so
yeah it's [ __ ] like when a movie or
no movie i'm active you know like
that's what i was gonna say out of the
group of guys you're the one guy who
just kind of
i mean you're just doing the dancing i
just still the other guy's kind of maybe
because i don't follow it as close
because you and i are boys but i see
what you're doing you're kind of the one
guy
who's just kind of doing it i've stayed
out there yeah
super active i've i've stayed active so
i was cool either way
um but yeah it was what we did in the
one week it went very well
paramount pictures a as i understand it
is just
thrilled with that with the whole idea
of it now so
we became a bigger priority on their
radar for when the world does begin to
spin again
it definitely stopped from this really
yeah no [ __ ] now dude do
i'm assuming they go and if this is too
much tell me steve
do they go through your agent to figure
out payment why is you what i'm saying
because
like now the terms are a little
different like you were a big star
you know what i'm saying you're totally
fine to ask and thanks for for flagging
you know the the sensitivity um
i did it's so funny man i in all the
years
leading up to i never even [ __ ]
countered
an offer i just found out what i was
going to get and i was like cool
right so like like on the other movies
because the reason i bring it up is
because
i was telling somebody at some random
fan at starbucks he's like oh who do you
have on today
and i was like stevo and he goes oh he
got did you hear him he got [ __ ] on
the other movies and i was like
no man no i didn't i didn't know that it
was uh
did we started out like the
big bad you know what he was talking
about
was the first season of the tv show
jackets
and for that i mean dude that's entry
level you gotta pay you knew how well it
would go
right 100 percent we would we'd gone
from making skateboard videos to now
we're on mtv
like we didn't get paid for the
skateboard videos and you know
so they were like okay for this first
season we're gonna pay you
like per bit you know each thing that
you shoot and if the thing that you're
shooting is uh really dangerous and you
could get
like you know hurt then we're gonna pay
you 500 bucks for that bit
if it's just like a funny prank or some
kind of a gag
you know then uh 200 bucks sounds cool
it sounds good like or just give us a
flat
fee man you would think that per episode
would be the the ticket but it was all
just like such a just a hodgepodge
yeah it sounds complicated is it because
they didn't know like
how big it would get like yeah they
didn't know what the [ __ ] they were
doing so um
they didn't know how many guys were
going to be a part of it you know
like there were like a bunch of
different characters in the skateboard
videos that sort of turned into jackass
they weren't even clear on who was going
to be uh the cast
you know they just sort of has i think
that's what what motivated that
but at the end of the day uh after taxes
i made
less than fifteen hundred bucks for the
first season
no residuals no not there why not you
know and then the other guys make
way more like did john johnny was kind
of the captain of the ship right for
sure
yeah he got like you know he's smart
dude all the the the producer [ __ ] the
residual [ __ ] the ownership and the
the creator [ __ ] you know like johnny's
a smart guy yeah and uh
ignite yeah
he's like he's a real reckless guy
more of a don king
whatever like from the project after
that
it got better it got better you know but
now this time around
and like i said i mean i i had agents in
the past but the agents were like okay
this is what you're going to get and i
was like
okay cool yeah this time around it's
like
oh okay well guys i need to speak up for
myself at this point because for the
last 10 it's been 10 [ __ ] years
since the last movie and so over the
last 10 years
like i've stayed active you know
yeah without like being a dick you know
like
i'm the only guy that [ __ ] has been
active you know like i've been
been building momentum i've been doing
my thing i think that it's safe to say
that at this point i bring more to the
table
than the rest of the i was going with it
without being offensive yeah yeah and
and i don't think that that's uh
a dickheaded thing to say it was like it
was an observation and then
what's more important for me is that i
i didn't want to like get in there and
be
the one like fighting for it i was like
hey you know what like
the last time around i had my lawyer
telling me yo
we've got a counter and i was like no
right and uh you know because the the
last time around i was newly sober
like i didn't know if i had it in me
yeah you know i was just like this was
for the movie
but for you
let me ask you a question do you ever
like do a stunt and you when you about
to do it you like
now it's just [ __ ] ah
especially now that you're sober you
know i feel like yeah
yeah i mean like in hindsight i i really
went on to regret
uh not letting my lawyer like fight you
know and so this time i just said hey
guys
i think i bring more to the table this
time around and this time i'm going to
stay out of my own way
and i'm going to do what my lawyer let
them do that
i'm going to let my guy do what he does
you know and uh
so i extricated myself from the the
you know the situation and my lawyer did
say this is [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
and and we and and then we uh kind of
got into the
the the standoff sort of so to speak you
know
and um it was just really something else
man i'd never really gone down that
path you know of where to find like
how contentious you know how like
it's heartbreaking it's sort of you know
it's like wow
like you know it's like wow
man like like when you're fighting over
money like
because we're not negotiating with uh
the parent with the movie studio
you know already the production company
give you a budget the production company
which is knoxville and spike jones and
jeff tremaine like
they've they've got their deal with the
with the studio
paramount pictures and so now there it's
up to them
to build it to deal with us so anything
that we get
comes out of their [ __ ] and so that's
what i came to learn is like wow they're
really [ __ ] pretty
they're pretty serious about digging in
their heels and and uh
getting real [ __ ] heavy over this and
um
the good thing is you know they can't do
it without like
hey there's a new jackass but there's no
steve i'm like
i'm not going it got to it got to a
point
where where my lawyer even was like wow
you know like
we got like you know we got a little
better
and you know at this point i just can't
tell i can't advise you to pass on this
you know
and then so i was like hey guys that's
all i needed was my guy to
say the word go and so yeah i don't
think that i got anything really
like uh uh substantial in the way of
like
i think it's a respect thing yeah it's
almost yeah you know what i'm saying
and whatever it was overall it was a
wildly uncomfortable process
you know like and and it is kind of
heartbreaking when it's like
when you're when you're bros but you
know i just come to learn that's the
nature of the world
[ __ ] it you know and this is show
business right yeah as soon as the deal
was done
and we showed up for that that one week
of filming
if i could all forgotten that we're
laughing our asses off the chemistry's
there the footage is great
do you guys still see each other outside
of this like do you communicate
sure is the band still yeah for sure
we've always been we've always been cool
we don't like
hang out all the time you know and it's
kind of like if something's really funny
like oh man like
i'll send this over that you know but uh
you know it's uh we're we're bros we're
all we're all a family and there's
there's no
hard feelings about anything and like
honestly
because i have been so active like
i stand to benefit so much more from the
film
than anybody else because you're on the
road your podcast
right i've got i've got established
revenue streams that are going to be
[ __ ]
supercharged by this so like this is if
i viewed the movie as just an
engine that's going to drive my other
evidence and more content
sure you're getting your content from it
yes everything
so it really was kind of a matter of
principle it was a matter of respect
my guy said go for it it's great plus
they got me a
producer credit which is kind of cool
second billing it's knoxville and stevo
oh cool man so i mean
there's a lot that's pretty [ __ ] cool
who comes up with the ideas
how we do because you guys have come up
with so much [ __ ] right you know what
i'm saying like
at some point it's like what else we
gonna do dude i don't know dude i know
but before somebody dies you know what
it's like right i
i know dude 100 percent and
when they pitch you guys on ideas
because i'm sure there's a group
is there every time we're like dude no
no no i'm not wrestling great white
big time hey fam it's been reported that
americans are overpaying on car
insurance by over 21 billion dollars
dollars dollars but searching for a
better deal can take hours typical
results in a barrage of unwanted spam
calls nobody wants that
until now thanks to the zebra.com
the zebra.com is the nation's leading
car insurance comparison
site because it's only place you can
compare quotes
side by side from over 100 providers and
choose the best
for you in 90 seconds or less try it out
plus they will never sell your
information to spammers
all you got to do is answer a few quick
questions it's simple it's fast
to find you the best rates boom you're
off and running
best part is it's completely free you
can save up to 670 dollars a year
by using the zebra.com how much can you
save on car
and home insurance go today and start
saving at the zebra.com
fighter that's the zebra.com fighter
spelled
t h e z e b r a dot com slash
fighter we are brought to you by the one
the only
on it dot com slash fighter 10 off the
entire
god damn site what do you need man i
keep preaching you guys to get the best
supplements on the planet
we got vitamins we got protein powder we
got keto stuff
we got coffee [ __ ] yeah coffee black
rifle
on it they collabed it's my favorite uh
coffee on the planet
they got caffeinated crystals in it it's
a dark roast it's hands down my favorite
coffee on the goddamn planet
get 10 off right now go to onnit.com
fighter
you need fitness gear kettlebells steel
uh
maces we got sandbags we got freaking
yoga mats we got
men's women's gear we got all we got
geez go to onit.com10 off you're welcome
is there every time we're like dude no
no no i'm not wrestling a great white
big time big [ __ ] time
in a general sense like on the third
movie
i was like okay guys look i [ __ ]
survived enough [ __ ] in my life now i'm
[ __ ] living clean and healthy and
[ __ ] you know and like
i'm really not okay with [ __ ] getting
in a goddamn wheelchair
[ __ ] dead at this point it would be
really [ __ ] dumb for me to have
survived all of this
i was like i was serious about it i was
like i'm not [ __ ] risking paralysis
or death okay
paralysis and death is not on the
[ __ ] table but if that's not
a concern then i'm in for everything
i opened for you in tempe when you
had the bandages oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
someone came to the green room yeah for
you uh-huh
i had third degree burns on 15 of my
my body i had skin grafts on 15 of my
body
and uh this was um steve will be working
for those of you
wait wait wait that was close that's the
closure for my new comedy special
which is uh which is uh available now
finally congratulations i i
i put it out of my own [ __ ] [ __ ] that
was when i was on there when i was duct
taped to that billboard
that's what that's what the billboard
was for i can't wait to tell you about
that whenever i go to a club i'm like
who who was here last week like steve
i'm like
just so you know i'm not this isn't i
can't i don't do any of that but i mean
dude it's all good man
and i'm psyched that uh you know
that's hard yeah we uh really um
like i travel with with one guy and we
do
we do our deal i think we've got a good
reputation on the the circuit right
everyone loves you yeah because i love
hearing the horror stories
that's my best it's my favorite thing
i'll sit down with a man gino by like
the second show on saturday everyone's
all cool you've done pressing stuff
together
now i'll go so who else have you had in
here yeah and then they just they can't
wait to tell it
oh my god we had blah blah blah two
months ago i'm like oh what else
it's like
[Applause]
this time around and i was really pretty
good on jackass 3d about that's why i
was like
i didn't have a problem with the the
porta-potty slingshot thing
because i was in like a five-point
harness you know like
it was as safe as as a ride at six flags
you know like really i mean then there's
like it was filled with dog [ __ ] yeah
the [ __ ] so like maybe there's like
hepatitis concern but i've never been a
germaphobe
i love how you broke that down it's safe
but the [ __ ] i can't hear
all
that was fine but now like over the last
10 years i've been like
you know i don't know i've just like
i've been going for it dude i've been
doing some like high level
[ __ ] [ __ ] and uh and so now
i'm like okay don't want to get
paralyzed i don't want to die and i'd
actually like to add brain trauma to the
you know i'm gonna i don't want to be
easy on concussions
oh yeah dude so we're that one week
we're filming we got we got this bit and
i just recognized this as
a completely concussion city [ __ ]
and i'm like dude i'm like wrong suited
up ready to do this thing and i actually
pulled the camera guy i'm going to get
over it
because i needed this documented i said
i came into this
with ground rules no brain trauma no
spinal cord injury no
like and we are not even one week into
production and i have
already thrown my [ __ ] rules out the
window yeah yeah so here we go let's
just cause we get around the boys is
he gonna say that we're talking to your
lawyer and when you're around the boys
like come on steve oh yeah
yeah [ __ ] it and what was crazy that
this bit involved a bunch of us doing
the same thing you know and it was like
we're all in it together
and so then it's like ready set action
and [ __ ] next thing you know i wake up
on the stretcher you know
i wake up i got ko'd
like like i would you know there's code
where you don't remember
you black out but then there's ko'd when
you're flat out unconscious
unresponsive you know and and then that
like like it was
everybody said like uh i don't know like
two minutes completely
not like not that's so scary totally
unconscious for two minutes that's not
good
i know it was because i don't know that
i've ever had
i know that i've had a couple
concussions that were that bad two
minutes though man
yeah that's a fight people are
concerned right and it happens all the
time too
yeah it's wait wait don't don't say it
like you bragging wait i want to know
wait what was the incident like stunt
you can't tell
your wife now though you're married for
those that don't right yeah i still
didn't get married i'm engaged oh you're
just waiting
for me but i'm sure she's like come on
she's [ __ ] pissed yeah she's like
dude you gotta chill the [ __ ] out i
didn't sign up
she's not pissing me she's pissed that
she didn't get a [ __ ] call
she's like if she's like can somebody on
the [ __ ] production let me know if
you're in a [ __ ]
ambulance yeah you know yeah she's
furious because she does it
she's still furious i bet because she
doesn't know you from the old days
right so she's probably like he's
chilled out he's vegan he's still doing
wild [ __ ] but
right it's not like i mean my guts [ __ ]
right my girl's a production chick she
was she was there when
when uh when i got all burned up you
know i like
she was telling me like on the i did a
bunch of stunts that led
to like the idea was
that uh
for my new comedy special right and and
the thing is like
i mean we have so much in common i think
in our
comedy um you know just that we're
crossovers that people
[ __ ] hate that word succeeding in
comedy
you're [ __ ] here they wanted i went
out a guy for stevo before yeah
yeah popular comic yeah they they uh
they [ __ ] wanna
they just they just wanna [ __ ] us to
not be they wanna say that we're not
[ __ ] funny and
and like and and whatever you know but
we both had
comedy specials in showtime yeah you
know and
you know to be fair i think it's safe to
say that we both did specials
like you know pretty early on you know
like where where i'm not bombed that i
did
the one special and and when i did my
first special showtime
it was as good as it could i could it
was the best [ __ ]
the best i had the best i was capable of
every time you know
and now i look back on it and now it's
like [ __ ] i've come so far since
agreeing you know i agree like if i put
out what i'm doing now would crush that
sure
but you know the way i look at it's like
i had the opportunity
i auditioned several times for it they
passed me for the special
so i was like well this is where i'm at
right now how cool would it be you know
because i'm gonna be doing comedy for
the next 30 40 years how cool would it
be if you could go back
and see say dave chappelle when he
wasn't ready
to see his special like oh that's dope
to see that and then where he's at now
that's
right that was my kind of frame of mind
going into it right
and like and then obviously people can
be like oh you're you're
you're special compared to chappelle's
with [ __ ] i'm like dude i'm doing comedy
for
two weeks yeah what do you want me to do
was so filled with like [ __ ] that nobody
would ever admit
you know they're in their right mind
like and and then that's what what
what's [ __ ] up about it no one's
hating on you or me
that is successful no like the reason
why
their anger comes from that place is
because somewhere along the line they
think they got
shafted and they see the success you're
having the tickets you're selling and
the
fan base that you have and they want
that and that's where the anger comes
so when i see that i'm like i get it man
i get it dude yeah
i get it sure right it's a dude and and
i i
thought that when i had my own special
come out on show time i was like oh dude
well then everybody's just gonna be so
shut the [ __ ] up now steve was gonna be
established as a stand-up comedian i'm
gonna be like
moving up to theaters it's gonna be
crazy my life's gonna explode
it got worse special came out nothing
changed
it gave the the the haters something to
focus on
nothing changed yeah nothing nothing
whatsoever like uh
i wasn't selling more tickets i was
doing exactly the [ __ ] same
and you know it seemed that
very few people like commented about
having even seen it you know
it was just like it's strange right it
didn't get like i mean i guess because
the media is so fragmented
you know like it's a different world now
it's just a different world when it
comes to specials
right like so many of them but then also
to this point you can relate to this
it's like
you know you're you're not posting the
countless time you put into
doing that special and how many shows
you do on the road like
for ca i think uh two years ago this
previous year before all this coverage
should happen
cia goes you're you did the most cities
out of any comic we have man
so no one they don't see that grind that
goes in
to get into that special it's so funny
when you put it that way but they also
don't see how you're bringing home a
check
every time you practice yeah that is
true
yeah this is bad it's a beautiful
it's a beautiful system the way that it
works but as i got
into developing my my follow-up you know
at the hour right like and uh from when
i taped the first special
to when it came out what was it like i
don't know like
five months maybe six months so like i
started getting into new material
you know so that i i like the transition
wasn't i'm starting from scratch you
know as soon as i taped it
i came out i worked on new material and
then fell back on
what i had that worked so by the time
the special came out i was really close
to having a whole new act
you could tour right yeah so i never
decided i didn't stop touring in that uh
in that space as i put together that new
hour
you know i i i had this experience and
[ __ ] made my head explode i was like
telling these these
just over the top [ __ ] crazy stories
which is
like what my stand-up is is comprised of
and
i was on stage performing the new
material and i thought
holy [ __ ] the [ __ ] stories that i'm
telling in this new act
pretty much all happened on camera so
what if i made my next special
multimedia so that you're not just
watching like me performing it's a show
but there's footage edited into it like
a multimedia standpoint what's a one-man
show
for sure and as soon as i thought
multimedia stand-up comedy
like footage cut in i was like oh my god
i think this is going to be so [ __ ]
broadway brother very few yeah
very few comedians tell stories that are
true
you know and not only are mine true but
there's like footage to back up
like you know every absurd detail have
have you ever seen uh
i think hassan minaj you know he had a
daily show correspondent and then when i
very first was getting a stand up
uh someone's like you should go see this
guy's show because i had an id
similar idea uh where you would have
graphics behind you telling your story
then doing stand up but telling the
story at the same time
behind you'd have video or pictures from
childhood well they go
there's a guy who's doing that right now
so is hassan minaj won the first show
i've ever saw
and he does that it was a live show it
was so good man
he's telling the story of him being an
immigrant uh he's he's indian descent
uh immigrant and coming from where he
came from and coming to america
and he has all these pictures and videos
when he's a kid and coming over on the
boat
it's nuts man it's for sure but it was
the same thing
who does michael yo yeah it was like it
was like a one-man show was so good
the way that i was doing this was was
all in in post though
you know i i let the stand up sort of
like
and it's all stand upstairs and it's all
right you know and then do it in post
um and uh and what i did when i came up
with this idea i wasted no [ __ ] time
going and filming my shows and then
bringing in to the computer and cutting
it all together
this was the most transformative
thing and i couldn't have even seen it
coming but
up to that point i like like a lot of
comedians
cringed at the idea of watching footage
of
my performance there's nothing wrong
it's just it's there's you have to do it
for your special
i mean i doubt i was very involved in
that i hated it i was very involved in
the editing process
yeah i was very involved and it was it
was difficult yeah and that's
the most [ __ ] recklessly
irresponsible thing i think
a comedian can do is refuse to watch
footage of their performances you know
like i think that you
have to and all the top dogs do like
rogan you know
with netflix usually they have someone
that does the editing stuff like that
rogan does it himself
yeah i believe it you're talking he
spends days hours hours
hours weeks editing making sure the cuts
right the angle is right yeah
and i refused to watch footage of my
performances for like those first five
years
as soon as i came up with this idea and
now i'm cutting the footage in
then i'm on the computer yeah and with
putting it all in the timeline sticking
the footage in
that forced me to study
my my act and you got you get better
from it infinitely
[ __ ] so so much because there's so
many everything that makes you
cringe is that's that's a note there's a
reason yeah that's that's
it that's a note that you need to
address yeah and so it's like oh [ __ ] i
hate this
this is this little and i i just
systematically addressed all these
things and the
the progression in my performing was
was just sped up so day and night right
it's like this
because you know the right the something
that you're doing that's not right that
you're uncomfortable
yeah and you're like uh i shouldn't be
doing that right for whatever reason as
soon as you make that note
then we want the phone the stage
whatever the next night
it's gone it's still a gradual process
but god it speeds up so much
when you're when you're studying the
footage and and and cutting the footage
into it
it worked so well you know and dude this
is like and
i've got footage where it's like the the
act was
it was largely a journey through my
criminal record
you know and i'm like i'm like i was out
on bail facing [ __ ] eight years in
prison
and that's when i flew over to europe
and got arrested again
yeah damn for international drug
smuggling
and i have footage of me doing all the
international drug smuggling getting
arrested it's all on camera
and like the stories are so [ __ ]
crazy and like
uh i'm putting it all together my head's
exploding it's just something this is so
[ __ ] dope you know and uh wha
what happened then was i started
thinking well if there's anything i was
going to criticize about this act is
that it's all like just so
you know memory lane [ __ ] like i don't
want to spend the rest of my life
like regaling the past you know
so i was like let me figure out ways
ways to plug so i
let every bit in the act inspire
something completely new like a whole
[ __ ] crazy
stunt you know so it's like an old story
and like because of that i decided to do
this
to nod to that by doing this
and uh so now i'm plugging in all new
[ __ ]
you know like new stunts and and
building that into the act
and then i was like okay so now that now
it's coming together so huge
now i need an an insane opening sequence
i knew i was going to film the special
in denver
but i got the whole jackass cast
together for the first time in
it we hadn't all been together in one
spot since uh ryan dunn died yeah you
know
and this was like a very [ __ ]
significant thing
and we we did that in la i told the guys
i got like this billboard truck that
like with the ones that drive around las
vegas
and i made a billboard for the actual
comedy special itself even though i
haven't taped it yet
i've got the billboard for the [ __ ]
comedy special and there's a big space
we're gonna duct tape me to it
and i want you guys to do the taping to
take me to the side of this [ __ ]
billboard truck
do whatever the [ __ ] you want i don't
care just you know
that you you have absolute open season
on me
and then once you get done taping me
this [ __ ] truck is going to drive
down the goddamn highway
you know i love it that must be dude
they're going man yeah
i didn't know yeah full on and uh and
and
i mean under the tape we had a harness
but that was it like you know
transparent in the you know you see it
it's it's so gnarly
knoxville hit baseballs at me while i
was taped to this [ __ ]
that's funny he hit baseballs at me
so what so like
i would say so so like
like horrifying and hard like horrifying
like if they're like
i mean dude it's uh i have a cup on
dude i know nothing but a diaper
why would that be to and so so we knew
that we knew that uh
like if they're getting out of la that
like it's just gonna be a bus trader
they're gonna
so what we did was like when i got they
got done
taping me to the truck they mounted a
[ __ ] box
over me there's it looks like uh almost
like a
like a coffin stuck to the side just
mounted over me so i was every bit duct
taped to the truck
but i put the box over me to get me out
of l.a
and uh then once we got to [ __ ] what is
what's the town before barstow
we [ __ ] they unscrewed the box so i'm
just still taped
flying down the [ __ ] highway i don't
know if we went 100 miles an hour but
this is whatever you know
like yeah and uh we went all the way to
vegas
um until then and then once the sun came
down and then
we wrapped for the day and uh we picked
it up with the sun coming up
in uh colorado like colorado springs and
every so we got the sun so we just we
pieced
where did you guys shoot in colorado uh
where's the gothic theater oh nice man
yeah it's a great place
yeah and so dude it was so symbolic too
to have like the whole jackass game
because
when i got into stand-up it was they
weren't like mean to me but it was like
oh yes
with your stand up
and like it was like [ __ ] dude like i
you know you know
actually when i started doing stand up
it was ryan dunn who was the most
supportive
you know he was like [ __ ] up you know
like bam was pretty
i mean they weren't like you know the
guys who are supportive i don't think
people realize it like means the world
dude like it means the world means
everyone else like come on dude
right means the world and there was
there was like a little bit
i'm not gonna say anybody was like a
dick to me but you know
they don't take you serious though they
they don't take it seriously okay so i'm
sorry
how long is he gonna do this right how
long you do this what's next
but by the time we film that opening
sequence for my new special the
the name of it is gnarly like it was
just
this i mean i'm like emotional about it
you know you get the whole
gang every every one of every one of us
together for the first time like
to like symbolically tape me to this
truck
and like send me off yeah it's like
goosebumps right sure yeah
it's like that's like this is the
symbolism of that you know
all the guys come together to support me
and send me off
to the theater to really [ __ ] launch
and now that they see the success you've
had in stand-up i'm sure they're all
about it now
and and not only did they send me off to
the theater
but the [ __ ] guys flew out for the
for the show itself
and intermittently came out throughout
the show and did
over-the-top stunt on the stage as well
god i bet the fans went
yeah i mean we we had uh non-stop didn't
go out for the actual live show he was
there for the opening sequence
bam was in rehab and uh everybody else
how's bam doing by the way
i mean not good
it's uh it's tough man i wish that uh
you know like when he had his real like
[ __ ] meltdown and he's
coming up with his own alphabet and he's
[ __ ] like all over tmz and he's
getting arrested left and right
i was thinking yes you know he's he's
wondering who is that
you know he's on the bottom he's where i
was at this is what it takes
yes you know we're gonna now he's gonna
[ __ ] do it like
trying and he's just still you know
like i feel like he he reached that
because
that was the problem i saw for the
longest time
and and and for what i'm so grateful for
myself which is that
i got so [ __ ] bad it had to stop you
know i would like like
only one way to go there was no there
was nothing [ __ ] okay
about what i was up to at the end of my
run with drugs now
and that was but what's strange me too
for for you i mean it helped a lot of
people so thank god but
that's documented too yeah i've seen
that
it's [ __ ] it's heartbreaking man yeah
and what's weird is john knoxville goes
in and because you guys are such boys
like you can tell like johnny knoxville
god bless him has like a switch where
he's like
no this isn't this isn't cool man like
we're not here
to film and you know no one's doing that
[ __ ] we're here to help
that's why we're [ __ ] here yeah for
sure and uh
you know i i i say it all the time like
you know we identify as alcoholics and
addicts it's like part of our deal
in recovery and uh i always say that you
know i'm an alcoholic i'm an addict and
i'm
grateful that i suffer from alcoholism
and addiction
so [ __ ] bad that i don't have to
wonder
if i belong in this program of recovery
yeah you know
i don't have to the right spot that's
the worst the worst situation
you could be in in my view is to just
have alcoholism
just kind of like just suffer from
addiction just enough that gray
that like that it's not so bad that it
absolutely has to stop but it's just bad
enough that it can [ __ ] up your
everything that you do just bad enough
that you can just makes make
poor decisions you can just waste a ton
of time
you can just not be motivated it's not
accomplish anything
so it's just bad enough to [ __ ] up your
life so that the
years turn into decades just slipping
through your fingers
you know where in my case it was so
[ __ ] bad i had so clear-cut i
had to get sober and then once i got
sober it's like oh wait a second
now i'm not wasting a lot of time
getting loaded so i can be going in the
wrong direction making messes
but you have to be kind of a north star
kind of you know
uh an example for bam and these other
attitudes
right like you should be a north star
because like look at steven he's [ __ ]
crushing it man like you guys could do
this i wish
and i don't know what it says about me
but some of my best friends are all
addicts
you know they're uh recovering you know
i mean dude it's it's the way to be like
the thing like alcoholism and addiction
is the only disease
where when
when you you get it you find after once
you
treat the disease any other disease you
treat it
and your best hope is to get back to as
good as you were before you got it
but alcoholism and addiction when you
treat that
you actually become an improved version
of yourself than you were before
no other disease do you still struggle
with this stupo i mean whatever like
you don't think because you when you're
when you're cause being on tour like
being the economy clubs like
to be honest i didn't drink or do
nicotine or anything before i started
doing stand-up
then i was around the scene and then
rogan was like oh i take a shot before
every set
uh and it was like a big night at the
comedy story he's like have a shot with
me like dude
i need all my wits when i'm up there's
like i'm telling you i've been doing
this a long time
this is a real action like all right
i'll do it settle my life
dude off to the races now now you know
i'm drinking
every set i have my own whiskey coming
out you know what i'm saying so it's
like
it's like alcohol and drugs kind of go
hand in hand a little bit with what we
do
you know because you're every club like
that's how they make their nut too
yeah okay sure plus the i'm the sober
guy and my
my crowd drinks like more than anybody's
crap
you take pictures with every single
person yeah i remember that you took it
that's so great
every single person i can't believe you
genuinely that's unbelievable yeah i've
always seen that like i feel like it's
self-serving
if i can send everybody possible
home with a photo and they're going to
post on their social media they're going
to tell all their friends i had a great
time at my show
it's like grassroots promotion i think
that really helped me
you know um but you don't struggle with
that with it being in the
stuff like that at all i don't i don't
spend a lot of time
like i can't i don't want to be like
cavalier
and and overconfident and say i don't i
don't think about you know
drinking but like really i might travel
with the sober guy
you know i'm my dude that i traveled
you're not around your fiance's
obviously sober
she's just never had an issue you know
she
she's never gotten loaded around me she
doesn't get loaded you know yeah she'll
smoke weed
sometimes but never around me yeah it's
just not an issue for her but uh
she so it's not um i i
i just kind of am i'm plugged in with
like the
the recovery community i don't feel that
i'm like um
like at risk of of getting loaded
because
like i'm sort of i am vigilant about
the you know whatever the program um but
with that said you'll hear people who
are clean and sober
those they say something that's pretty
like legitimately terrifying
which is that uh i never
suffered from alcoholism until i got
sober
because if you think about it the
disease has not really got anything to
do with
drinking the drink it like the disease
is this underlying
sense of of uh like
discontent restless irritable yeah
yeah so you're drinking to the actual
alcohol is
is a symptom of the of the disease you
know like it's actually
you could even go one step further the
alcohol is the
the solution that's the your medicine
yeah for the disease
and then all of a sudden the medicine
turns on you and everything that drove
you to drink is still
you know you take away the alcohol and
now you're actually suffering
you got to deal with it yeah that's why
it's so important to have the community
of
recovery you know that's why did you go
to a therapist
i'm still or no i've had
people yet because after the [ __ ] uh
drugs and i got sober with drugs and
alcohol and uh
you know i was a couple years sober and
and uh started the comedy tour
and the thing about taking photos with
every single audience member possible
like uh this is you know still to this
day
before i get off stage i i will not go
anywhere
or do anything until i take a photo with
every single one of you guys the whole
the whole audience like you know
basically for the most part
forms a line oh yeah you know i formed
the line i could and and for the
first the first however many years of my
comedy tour
that meet and greet was a glorified
[ __ ] audition
to figure out who i was going to act out
with sexually that night
you know like straight up and uh
that's what that's what it is it just
dawned on me
i'm sorry i was a little late but i got
it
like people don't want to talk about
them but that might be the worst
addiction because it's like
you don't realize it but it's like it's
totally another addiction
if you think about like what's taken
down like the most like
uh you know successful people like
destroyed the most likely
you know that sex is by far more
destructive
by far too that then drugs now cause i
think
so how'd you deal with that stuff but
the way that it went down
i was like at this point i want to say
uh i was like 38
39 and i remember going to
um going to atlanta the punch line where
the
the club owner is chris depe and uh you
know my act at that time was all about
just like
the groupie sex like the triple blow job
the you know
like this it was just super blue and and
and i remember after my show chris japan
was like man was like what are you doing
dude what are you doing with your comedy
yeah he's like he's like he's like sure
you might be getting away with it now oh
it's getting my dick sucked but do you
really wanna you know you're getting to
an age where like
is that really what you want yeah like
put out there like
you're getting it's just kind of creepy
really you know like
and and and the thing was that that was
my lifestyle you know
and i was like [ __ ] he's right and so
the way that
the way that it unfolded i started to
think okay i'm 38 like
i like i'm almost 40. do i really like
do i want to be living this lifestyle
you know
i had this awful joke where i said you
know
like uh how you know
40 like do i you know i have to ask
myself do i want to be
50 and physically falling apart
and trying to hump everything that moves
it's so sad
i don't want to turn into polly sure
but so i was like and i just recognized
that this wasn't the way to be happy let
me ask you this
too when you're doing those meet and
greets and at the time i mean it's well
known i'm not saying anything the
viewers don't or
listeners don't know but you you there's
time you're dating kat von d
which was a super public relationship
it's not like if you were flirting with
girls like people are aware that you
have this famous girlfriend right now
and at the time you guys were like
you're like a power couple yeah that
that
which is awkward too you know that that
came later it was
like at the end of 2015 the cat and i
got in uh this
fairly brief relationship um during 2013
i uh i started out by saying look you
know
i i subscribed to the idea that future
happened being really happy
contingent on me learning how to have a
healthy relationship
you know like i just like to have a life
partner to not
just with all the [ __ ] time wasted
chasing chicks distracted it's
such a distraction but it's such a
distraction such a time
waster there's just all kinds of
attendant stress
and then it's like you know you see when
you're ghosting chicks and you feel like
the [ __ ] worst piece of [ __ ]
it's just the word you know there's
everything about it was just [ __ ]
awful and i was like this isn't this
isn't the way
so i i made a conscious decision i
promised myself
like i'm i'm not going to [ __ ] fool
around with chicks on the rim to stop
acting out on the road i'm going to know
like i'm just gonna like address my
you know my my behavior and yeah i
couldn't [ __ ] do it
this is like the you know i identified
the
it's just a full addiction i broke my
promise every trip
i'd come back and be like [ __ ] i did it
again i would say it's the toughest
thing in the world
yeah people i don't think people
understand but that would be one of the
toughest addictions
that was when i got into therapy yeah
that was when i got into therapy and a
therapy
a therapist that uh specialized in in
sexual addiction and uh and you know
did she have you texting me he was a
dude
on the road and it just turned in it it
just
flowed out it became comedy it flowed
out yes
my my whole act went from like like i
i you know i never stapled my ball sack
to my leg for the joy of it
yeah i did it to get laid you know like
i wanted to get [ __ ] like [ __ ]
and and then when jackass came out and
all of a sudden this happens
you know like uh it was that was my act
and then it turned into like but i don't
want to be this way so i tried to stop
and like
you know i said i'm not gonna float
around with any chicks and then
the next trip i go on there i am in in
uh
the titty bars
it's missing impossible i was just oh
i was there for the wings
dude i was minding my own [ __ ]
business and
and and this is a completely true story
too minding my own business
this this dancer and uh
she comes running over just bee lines it
for me she's just
like she comes hauling ass over and
swivels around sticks her butt in my
face
i look at it and she had literally
my autograph tattooed on her butt cheek
what can you say how am i supposed to
turn down a piece of ass with my name on
it
for you and everywhere i went something
like that happened i kept breaking my
own rule
and then my god and so then like
the uh the therapist tells me i gotta uh
stop i gotta go for a period of celibacy
like no
no fooling around no jacking off no
nothing oh wow
and i'm like i'm trying to do it and i'd
like you know
there was one there was one serious
thing that happened it was a joke where
i was in the bathtub
and like the line between hygiene and
romance got a little blurry
i ended up taking myself on a date
and uh
the therapist says you gotta you know i
i think you need to go into
like an actual like program you know
like sex rehab
and i did that and i come out of the sex
addict rehab i'm all in just like i was
with drugs and alcohol
but i'm coming out of the rehab and i
got all these tour dates
and i'm like there's no i don't stand a
chance
so that was when i reached out to my guy
who i traveled with i was like hey dude
can you come with me on this trip to
tennessee
hold me accountable because he's in both
programs
you know he's he's using both programs
and i was like dude i just need you to
come
and cockblock for me yeah you know i was
just just be there
when i do the meet and greet and you can
always i told him i always hire
hire i always get somebody from the club
to sell
my books and t-shirts and i give them
like a buck a sale you know
and i was like you can do that so what
you'd get so he comes to cockblock and
it's super effective
and he's like dude you don't have a
credit card swiper you're only selling
books and t-shirts dude i've been
touring with that [ __ ] guy
for the for almost seven years
we started in january 2014 and now
we have dick pic pens steve
stevo sunglasses steve
socks we've got [ __ ] all kinds of
[ __ ]
oh dude i turn every [ __ ] show into a
flea market
my dog has a [ __ ] merch line
i love it yeah and uh it's crazy in this
[ __ ] merch operation
like where we're like traveling [ __ ]
production team
like we're shooting all this stuff i got
into where i did that first but
the first special was like the arc of
like you know becoming famous
sexual addiction and then working on
kind of growing up so i can have a
healthy relationship
and like to the extent that that's you
know as
how blue it was how uncomfortably like
graphic sexual [ __ ] it was that it like
dude
i stand by it man like that that that
was my experience it was
you know i [ __ ] loved that thing but
again it didn't change my life
then the uh the follow-up special now
i'm dude
dude it's something else man have you
seen what uh
schultz is doing andrew schultz do you
know who sure
yeah thank god he doesn't have to say
now turn your phone
because igtv figured it out so if you
turn the phone up it just works
yeah and he has some big deal coming out
from that because so many people
gravitated towards what he was doing on
those
instagram stories which i don't want to
air his business out but
you know what he's doing with just
releasing the clips and
how you know he he is doing an hour
special but releasing
these clips you know because everyone
has such a short attention span
and the amount of tickets he's selling
just off
just those kind of hot clips man he's
crushing it i don't know if you've
considered that
not that you need to wait when you say
uh putting clips like
put like a four minute bit out stand up
or he'll put out his crowd workout or
you know he always has a guy every show
he goes to is a guy
recording just in case there's some hot
crowd work
you know because right you know how it
is when you do crowd work there's some
dumb ass in the front row and you're
going to roast them or whatever it is
right it's that special time
you can release that because you're
never going to get that experience
getting [ __ ] he's
that guy's blowing up man he's great
yeah i mean i've seen a bunch did like
he had one of his things in his little
studio setups talking about biden and it
was so [ __ ] funny dude his takes on
the political stuff yeah and that's why
he's at where he's at now you know he's
doing this big project for it yeah yeah
i know and
it's crazy it brings up all kinds of uh
just curiosities i have about this sort
of east versus west thing going on in
comedy like
this is schultz is new york yeah as new
york as it gets
yeah yeah it's kind of sad and he comes
out here sometimes you know he's part of
the crew out here
but he you know he comes out here and
then tim dillon was a straight new york
guy he moved to la
and now he's doing you know podcasting
he's in the circle but
now he's super you know west coast it's
it's interesting
right it is and and
before we get into that i just want i
just want to
direct people too this is what i did
with the the new special i put it out
on my own website it's at stevo.com you
click
it's so [ __ ] explicit you gotta
[ __ ]
watch.com it's the official steve
website bring that up
in order to [ __ ]
okay so go ahead and click on
me duct tape to the billboard truck it's
going to make you confirm that you're
18.
look at that picture okay hit play on
the trailer
dude you got to see the [ __ ] you got
to see
this is going to be noxious pretty
gnarly you gotta
hit this are we ready yeah dead
[Music]
oh [ __ ] wait
no no
like i i don't wanna i originally can
paint their boobs and show them on
instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and
oh
steve oh yeah embrace ourselves wait you
set yourself on fire
that's where you got the birds that's
why i got the the burn
who's not going to see that clipping
right yeah i'm buying this right oh
god oh no oh my god you're not about to
swallow a condom you're not about to
swallow a cat
i swear i swallowed a full load of my
bros cup
your bros my bro blew a load in the
condom before i swallowed it
i feel sick people you could have left
me you could we could
you could have just told us fantastic
that was
great so so that's the reaction to the
tread the whole [ __ ]
i just [ __ ] love you dude bro
i've been following you since i was a
little kid thank you man you told these
guys that yeah they said get ready steve
yeah i'm a dude i'm geeking out you
changed shopping carts for me you know
y'all used to
watch i used to go there and sit there
and let my mom push
go faster like how you're doing jackass
mom i think it's smart what you're doing
though releasing on your
own website yeah i can tell you about
the business of it yeah i'd love to hear
it
there's been guys who have done it
before but they don't
uh kind of command the same audience
that you do like i'm sure
it's going really well for you because
like louis ck has done that before
there's been guys who've done it before
luis k was super prolific in doing it
and not only did he do his uh
his louis series he did his the initial
window on his website and then
sold it to fx i think yes correct which
is crazy i don't think that that
did you know he released i think it was
either a series or special and he wanted
to see
what doing kind of promotion without
doing it
how many views he'd get just word of
mouth right you want to do an experiment
really did no promotion
and he was like i don't know if
promotion matters that much so i'm just
going to release it i'm not going to say
anything
that was a recent one no he did uh years
ago oh
we see a lot of uh like beyonce doing
that like eminem surprise albums
yeah and they crush it's like the fact
that it's a surprise makes everybody
else
but i think you kind of betting on
yourself is like
i just think it's the move man i think
there's so many comics and
people in show business they're waiting
for that approval from
from the from the man they're waiting
for these huge networks to go right
okay we think you're funny we think
you're good enough it's like well
i have what you guys want i got a
built-in audience and they know what i'm
about and they're down man yeah so i'm
either gonna do it here
if you guys don't do this i'm gonna do
it here so it's gonna work one way right
now it did this is it's there's the of
course
like the there's so much
nudity there's so much [ __ ] like
heavy drugs
like grievous bodily harm criminal
activity
there are a lot of reasons why this was
never going to be a
ah it was never gonna have a chance at
comedy central they would never
like the only places i could have sold
it were going to be
netflix or hbo or showtime and did you
try that
i did yeah i [ __ ] taped that thing
okay just shooting it that the night of
the spell you can see it's
properly produced really what was it
[ __ ] 125 thousand dollars
for the filming of the special itself
but then like just the opening sequence
you know we filmed in la we filmed in
in denver i flew all the jackass guys in
like rented
all that like by then then all of the
the vignettes all of the the additional
bits every one of them was
was a shoot in its own right by the time
i got done actually she's shooting the
[ __ ] special i'd spend over a quarter
million dollars on it
and then and then let alone like by the
time i you know i put it out
i thought it was like 300 grand you know
but
that that's up to present day that
[ __ ] special
was taped in denver in january of 2018.
i [ __ ] i knew how dope it was
and i [ __ ] put put it to i got it
done
and then i i [ __ ] that the
agents would like uh brought it to
to to every you know and netflix this
guy
uh who buys comedy specials he was just
like you know
i'm like a comedy snob you know
i don't want to give a comedy special to
somebody who's not a lifelong
like comedian like uh we're really more
interested in like giving 20 million
dollars to david chappelle
you know or like or whatever you know
[ __ ] they have on there
i mean they agree they greenlit uh i
think 800 comedy specials on there
right right and i just couldn't [ __ ]
figure it out but netflix wouldn't go
for it
and then in hbo and showtime at the same
time i don't know they're like
there's too many specials out there so
we we like
the like we want this is the most
prestigious one and i was like what
i felt like [ __ ] dr dre on
his defiant ones i was watching that and
he said it's a great year
he said that when he [ __ ] finished
the chronic he brought
the chronic to every record label every
record label
passed on and they rejected the [ __ ]
chronic and he was like no i believe in
it
and i think that's that's how he started
aftermath or some [ __ ] yeah
and i was just like dude i got the
[ __ ] chronic this is
this [ __ ] thing is the chronic and i
was just bashing my [ __ ] head against
the wall to figure out how to put it
together on my own website
finally i i i put it together and very
recently it only just went up
but when uh but i put it out on my own
and um i put it out in july
by the time i was duct taped to that
billboard i'd already gotten my money
back correct
i i already got my money back and that's
and it's a lesson
for for other comics it's like all all
these guys are waiting for the netflix
and the show time they should be able to
go
yeah we think you're good enough it's
like man [ __ ] pain
don't wait on that because like you said
take it from me and steve it's not
a lot of times it's not life-changing on
there it was if even if you get on
hate tell you feeding on the monster of
all monsters netflix
i know a million comments who get on
netflix they don't sell
another extra ticket it does nothing no
because they they get lost in the
shuffle yeah unless you're one of those
big boys
algorithm like the last one that i know
for a fact
changed his life and i don't know if
anyone's ever going to see the same
return but nate bargatsky
he's a phenomenal comic finally had his
chance got on netflix
it was just the right timing the
algorithm it was like oh bill burr
special well you might also like nate
bargatzi
and then he's his career blew up and he
has the talent and he's been doing
putting in the work
but for the most part a lot of guys i
know who are on netflix
showtime or hbo it just doesn't work
that way man yeah yeah that means crazy
dude
um good for you stevo i did now the kids
but i was so i was so [ __ ] pissed
because i
knew i made them like that just the fact
of the multimedia like from start to
finish this entire hour special
like is it it's completely packed with
every [ __ ]
joke you're watching what i'm talking
about you know they're like it's it's
completely loaded from start to finish
with just bananas [ __ ] footage yeah
and then like half of it's completely
new
plus it's got the whole cast of jackass
plus i got [ __ ] skin graft surgery on
fifteen percent of my [ __ ] body for
the ender
yeah you know like don't you think the
fit like and i think two one of the
reasons why it's a success is
fans realize what you're doing you know
what i'm saying it's like
there's something that turns them off
when you do get on netflix or hbo
showtime
i think when fans realize that you put
all your blood sweat and tears in this
you're banking on yourself yeah 99.9
percent of people go oh i can [ __ ] with
that yeah
because they get it man because so many
people have been shafted by the men i
was so [ __ ] pissed i was so [ __ ]
pissed at netflix i'm so [ __ ] pissed
at everybody who could
i actually filmed a [ __ ] thing
calling them out in the credits but
here's my
i put it i put it in the credits here's
my thing with that steve well thank god
they did that right yeah i
only got the same return right i know at
the time when they turn you down it's
[ __ ] heartbreaking because
when i first started touring as a
headline comic i had clubs that wouldn't
let me come to their club
certain clubs my favorite club the
commonwealth's in denver i grew up in
denver
i heard about it it was my favorite club
that went we can't have brendan we can't
have headline
we're just let's let's give it more time
and so
finally like a year went by and my
agent's like i'm telling you this this
kid
he's doing he's at the kami story he's
the improv he got passed at the ice
house
you should give him a shot they went
we'll give him a thursday we'll give him
one show on thursday if he does good on
thursday
then the following year we'll see what
happens i do that thursday
following year they offer me a full
weekend but it's like that
like to me like my initial reaction was
like all those clubs i made a mental
note
all those clubs like [ __ ] those people
yeah and then you realize like oh
it's not it's not that they don't like
you it's just
you know they're during this kind of old
school mentality right
it's just this old school mentality
right well here's here's what i did
yeah that's fantastic
here's what i do i already [ __ ]
i it lit launch strong i got my money
back and i was like okay you know what
i'm gonna do now
i'm gonna [ __ ] buy a billboard in in
hollywood i picked one that has the
[ __ ] hollywood sign prominently
behind it right i already [ __ ] got
like in
crazy trouble with the climbing up the
crane
yeah and i'm off probation right
but i'm off probation i was like you
know what i was like you know what that
billboard's not cheap you know
or whatever it's eight grand you know
eight thousand bucks for the month
like and then add on top of that to get
me up there and mount me on to it you
know i gotta hire an entire construction
team
two cranes you know i'm [ __ ] this you
know
and i'm yeah maybe i'm gonna get myself
in some [ __ ] trouble maybe it's gonna
you know
but but
i think that uh that this is gonna this
is gonna
they're gonna [ __ ] find out about
this so i
i go up on that billboard and and for
the first hour like nobody seems to care
a cop [ __ ] kind of
slows to a roller sticks his cell phone
now [ __ ] snap shot
and i'm like dude i just because that
was largely what brought
the whole budget for the special over
300 grand you know
and uh and then i show up on this
citizen app it says man duct tape to
billboard and
some some it's supposed to be like local
in your neighborhood but somehow like
700 000 people have [ __ ]
like uh viewed that like there's a live
stream or something
and um once that happened dude now
there's hundreds of people everywhere
and [ __ ] like
cops and fire trucks and i'm like oh
dude i really don't want the [ __ ]
fire department to do this
i kept my construction team there and
then the the guy comes straight to the
first responders he says
hey look we have a whole team we've got
our own cranes we can bring them down
it's completely safe you don't have to
waste your time
and they were like oh well it's the
liability that we we have to
take him down you know but
but it did its job though it did its job
because within
48 hours of me coming down off of that
billboard there were
articles online that's all from all over
dude
from vanity fair i had never been
written up
by vanity fair before vanity fair
variety
rolling stone people magazine [ __ ]
buzzfeed
deadline tmz fox cnn
usa today [ __ ] it went on
and on and on it was
probably the most [ __ ] publicity i've
done publicity stunts in the past this
one might have been
that's a big boy it was a big one
there's a [ __ ] big one and i'm just
like those [ __ ] [ __ ] faces
what they could have had you know what
they could have and now like
now they need to understand that when i
make my
my neck special and and and
again i taped gnarly in january of 2018.
you have all new material oh dude i've
been touring now that now the
material comes with me on the road yeah
now each bit
and there's no there's no more memory
lane on my new tour now it's the bucket
list tour
it's the the [ __ ] bottom of the
barrel stunts that didn't happen for
damn good reasons and i went ahead and
did them anyway
and so it's a hundred percent all new
material
about new [ __ ] i did so i'm not regaling
the past anymore
and uh and and i'll be ready to do that
whenever i picture that when jackass 4
comes out
i'll have my bucket list special ready
to come out i'll have my
my new book ready to come i bet they're
going to be singing a different tune but
my question for you is do you want to go
down that lane that's the question you
still wanna you don't think
we know this works right and that's
without the netflix algorithm right
that's without their promotion machine
me
on my own all steps like uh yeah
well i think it's tough i think you know
for some comics and there's not a ton of
them but
some people are just undeniable you know
what i'm saying it's like you're
undeniable stupid yeah
you know and and i honestly like
wholeheartedly believe that every single
[ __ ] person who watched my special on
stevo.com who streamed it from there
like
is a completely satisfied customer yes
through and through yeah and that i'm
building goodwill with my audience
such that when i do put out my next
special they're going to be they're
ready to go again i was so happy that i
made that purchase last time around i'm
ready to do it again
and all i've just built built up the
machine so the next time around
and and likely we never know what the
world stopped spinning but
it's likely that jackass 4 will come out
in september
2021. i better do that yeah i'll have my
my
follow-up to my my book you know i have
a new book coming out but at the same
time
yeah like like uh it looks like i'm
selling a
television series to the usa network you
know
um and and then a new bucket list
special like it's gonna be like
potentially a big [ __ ] year next year
2021 is gonna be big
2021 could be really [ __ ] big and
dude
i jumped on the podcast bandwagon too i
know and your podcast is
doing well right that's what was great
about the the coronavirus shutdown
we were filming jackas4 for one week
during that week my agent called up
and said hey man like uh you're selling
out your
your shows in the comedy club so far in
advance
i it no longer makes sense to me to uh
and to even entertain offers from comedy
clubs
like congratulations you've graduated to
theaters jesus christ
it all goes away so that's what sucked
you know
that that all getting shut down sucked
but you know i've got like my
my my digital operation you know i've
got like i'm super active with the
youtube i have
the blessing because it forces a lot of
people to get creative
and figure out other revenue streams and
other content
yeah and and i already had the wheels in
motion for my podcast i had
three episodes banked when the the
uh coronavirus shutdown happened but
i just you know i had so i did a lot of
monsoon but you're doing it out of your
out of the trailer yeah dad said rv i
parked it on the street
right outside well you have rv you know
for years it was the most annoying
question like will you do my podcast i'm
like
you know because everybody's got a
podcast and most
most podcasters don't have an audience
you know like so it's like oh i hate
that question
and now i'm going to be the one asking
that question so yeah but a lot of
people know your favorites
yeah i suppose but but the only way that
i could wrap my head around jumping on
the podcast bandwagon was if i
if i could have a mobile studio that i
can bring to the guest
make it easy whenever it is convenient
for you wherever you want to have i'll
just pull up you jump in the rv
yeah i remember we were talking about
dude i'll just pull up to your house i'm
like what the hell yeah
yeah let's do it man and we still got to
do it we still got it so i gotta do it
i i i love that i'm saved because i know
that it's gonna be a [ __ ] killer yeah
you know booking i don't know for you if
you even
trip it that much but dude i agonize
over like trying to get
[ __ ] well huge names for for me it
was like
you know for the longest time doing fire
in the kid it was me and brian callan
and so we would have guests and then
became is just
me and brian so we weren't so guest
heavy because the audience was tuning in
because it's just me and brian and
the relationship to me and brian and
then i'll see [ __ ] hit the fan with
brian these allegations come and then
he can't be on the show and so i'm like
what the hell am i gonna do and then
you know thank god for chappelle and
malik and i i told kat i'm like i need
help man
i'm either going to stop doing the show
or i need help because i
i just you know i do two other shows i
do a show for show time
and i do the one with theo king and the
sting and it's like i'm spread so thin
if i have to take this on and then rely
on guests
well i'm not going to make it so then
yeah cat started booking and thank god
for catman
you know thank god because the guest is
it's such a beast man people don't
realize it's it's yeah i gotta
as [ __ ] right but he can't yeah he
doesn't do it for me like
he does it before he respectfully
doesn't uh hotbox yeah you can't
you can't hotboxes i mean yeah like some
people probably don't
don't care for me it's like i'm
breathing it in i don't know
how good was john it was great yeah i
watched the episode yeah yeah
thank you dude i thought i thought it
was it was really good
um yeah i was [ __ ] shaq dude i should
kill her
that's the weird one [ __ ] demi lovato
i love that's a big one
ronda rousey
[ __ ] uh tiffany haddish was a huge oh
hell yeah that's a
beast yeah you're stephen everyone loves
you yeah
dude thank you man you're great peoples
man i very genuine
everything that guy we don't have a date
but we're gonna have snoop
oh god yeah i can't wait for you is
there anybody you're like dying to have
on that you can't get on
ah [ __ ] man um i read that i don't know
why i
[ __ ] i haven't been able to book 50
but he's like mild bro 50 cents really
forgive uh zoom cause deer would have
been dope if shaq was in the rv because
he
yeah it's called wild ride with stevo
and uh it's a great podcast man yeah
tomorrow we put up ryan sheckler
oh i love hillary yeah he's rad dude i i
asked he said how on his mtv show
uh which ran for a number of seasons
that like he was
sort of going through growing pains of
being a teenager and like wildly
successful
and all on camera and his parents got
divorced while the show was filming
and i was like man you know uh
didn't like did your earnings
play into your parents divorce were they
like fighting over like
your [ __ ] but then i was like
i'm sorry i asked that [ __ ] up
question he's like oh no don't worry
about it
yeah i'm sure about telling you
everything dude dude so yeah like
that's what i've been doing in the
shutdown the coronavirus just been uh
are you are you gonna start booking some
tour dates or are you still
i just got my first offer for a drive-in
scenario
it might work for you i don't i've heard
good and bad like bert christopher he
loves everything so he swears by it
chappelle did one i didn't do it i'm
doing i'm straight up doing that as an
improv in dallas this weekend
so i'm back on regular all right do you
have the antibodies after you i do
you're dust up with something
people are so mean about it man yeah
people are brutal about it yeah
oh my god yeah i saw one particularly
[ __ ] uh
mean headline and you gotta discredit to
to credit the person for coming up with
the witty headline
like covid it said covet the only thing
killing at a brian sharp show
oh
you didn't get it i didn't get it nah
they didn't get it either right no
yeah i didn't i just said that just to
me
i don't know i'm sorry no that's
hilarious
funny headline headline um i did i uh
tested positive for the antibodies like
never
oh good for you i never even you might
have been asymptomatic i was totally
asymptomatic because there's never a
point where i felt even remotely ill
yeah it wasn't bad for me but everyone's
different but dude you know you're
always welcome here brother we're not
the [ __ ] man i'm not sure what you're
special tonight man i'm scared i'm just
proud of what you're doing man thank you
man it's not gonna let you down
and uh and then maybe i'll come maybe i
will do the bucket list
show dude the bucket list tour i [ __ ]
i went so overboard i'm looking forward
to
jackass for coming out and doing all the
press for it and being like yeah jack
has poor whatever
because i can confidently say that like
jack has
you know whatever happened to jacob the
gnarly [ __ ] is in
the bucket list correct okay like i was
like you know i had these ideas for
decades
that uh just it just wasn't in the cards
for them to happen you know like
like skydiving for for like 20 years
people ask me
about skydiving and i was like yeah
everybody does that that's not a stunt i
said you know
for it to be worth it for me to go
skydiving since the first time
you uh have to have a guy strapped on
your back
i'm gonna be butt [ __ ] naked
and furiously jacking off
and i'm gonna oh he
and i'm going to time it so that i fall
out of the airplane
blasting everywhere it's hilarious there
are a lot of layers to that there's a
lot
just a mental well dude there's a lot of
layers first off just
like the initial calls to the to the
compass hey i don't know if you ever
heard of stevo oh [ __ ] yeah we love
stephen whatever he wants to do we're in
and they're explaining explain the idea
and like a lot of silence on the car
yeah they had a lot of silence on the
call so then
we kept getting shut down like we called
so many and they were like oh no we
really can't do that you know like
so i said [ __ ] it they don't want to
[ __ ] it i go on my social media with the
instagram story i'm like hey i'm looking
for a professional skydiver
with a tandem license to do uh a stunt
with me
we got a million i do i [ __ ] uh
gotta have your license and like contact
my guy my cockblocker scott
scott scott tells me he's like dude we
got 72 licensed
tandem skydivers and i'm like right on
right now tell them the idea
like the the logistics the [ __ ]
plateaus
across that's that's the closer for the
bucket list i love that dude
i'm sure there's one or two they're like
yeah we're down
right yeah i don't know this one guy was
like [ __ ]
he's like i'll jack off with them
please let me be the one
yeah it's a foreign
start to finish on the bucket list show
if the if the world starts
spinning again dude i got like i always
want i don't
have kids so like i had an idea for the
longest time i'm gonna get a vasectomy
and do
like uh the vasectomy olympics we're
right out of the procedure i'm [ __ ]
yeah rigorous [ __ ] why don't you want
kids because [ __ ]
kids man number one might be number one
like
passing on my dna is very problematic my
family
tree is not like uh
it's just tough yeah like it's tough
it's like with the alcoholism and the
addiction and the
gambling yeah suicide like it's my whole
family tree on my mom's side
you know it's like the russian roulette
with a loaded gun
fully loaded um but then there's like
the just the
the dwindling opportunity the whole
[ __ ] dynamic of the rich get richer
and the poor get poorer stop being
[ __ ] funny
like you know it's not like the the
dwindling opportunity i don't have it in
me to
create a new person to swim against this
[ __ ] stream that just becomes more
powerful against you the odds to stack
like why you know why you know like
with uh they didn't take the coveted
[ __ ] right like
i i got interested in and uh okay well
how many people die anyway
right we're making such a big deal 200 7
500 a day yeah
i i i came up with the last uh
the last well-documented year was 2018.
it was 7 700 per day so like
how many of these coveted deaths would
they have died anyway right like i mean
i don't want to like
discount it but my sister did put it
this way she said you know
like when when world war one world war
two were like
like war situations happen like the
tragedy of all of that loss of life is
that everybody dying is
young like 18 year old super healthy
[ __ ] you know people but like my
sister said
you know without being like you know
like
like you know dickheaded or whatever on
the back
right and uh you know you've got people
with uh
you know vulnerability it's like you
know you could look at
covid as uh sort of the opposite of like
the the loss of life during during war
you know with all the young people dying
in this case you've got people who
really serve to be a drain on medicare
you know on on like whatever the
the you know [ __ ] bills and
everything so like
it's almost like kind of cleaning up the
system a little bit
and i mean call me a dick whatever like
uh
that's that was my sister who said that
but how many people die and then like so
here's the [ __ ] up part
seven thousand seven hundred people die
anyway every day and like eleven
thousand are born every day
yep um i mean what the [ __ ] nuts
what the [ __ ] right like
come on come on
and so it's like going to go get a
vasectomy and
i jump on a [ __ ] bareback horse in my
hospital gown and go galloping
like to the [ __ ] pinata party where
i'm the pinata
you know like and and i'm the weird one
you know like feel like like i'm the
weird one for
wanting to get a vasectomy like look at
this
its own man look at the numbers dude
whatever is best for your lifestyles
members are dumb yeah you know the
numbers are dumb they're like to have
more
kids it would be cool to have another
stevo on this planet you know what i'm
saying like you're a good person steve p
well i appreciate that i appreciate that
and uh you know like some people like
out of those eleven thousand
most of them probably shouldn't be
having kids i mean we could use more
stevo's like idiocracy
was like a funny concept but dude it's
not comedy it's the [ __ ] world that's
the truth
oh the movie with uh yeah yeah
luke wilson yeah cruz like the president
yeah it's like i mean just the the the
people having the most kids are just
right yeah i think that people are most
people who are most qualified
to be like i i think that you should
have to get a license to get to have a
kid
that's right i think you have to get a
license to catch a [ __ ] fish
yep it's true
yeah yeah drive a car yeah yeah kids
it's just whatever
right yeah you're right so so whatever
check out the special man stevo.com yeah
please do it
down inside i assume that clip
sells itself we don't really need to say
too much i mean
it's it's pretty indicative of uh of of
how [ __ ]
gnarly it is let me know man whenever
whenever you're ready i'll jump in that
yeah dude i love it man happy
i love it like uh i got theo coming on
uh imminently great it sounds like yeah
um yeah i can't wait i can't even wait
and there's just so much
that uh that we didn't get into on this
that i'm just
dying to ask people back you know like
yeah
so much [ __ ] to talk and we got a lot of
work to do
and dude thank you guys too no dude
i'm a living legend bro man thank you
anytime steve
we love you man ladies and gentlemen all
right
dude hell yeah steve is great right man
how about
man thank you thank you b great great
how long have you known him
uh i've known steve stevo came on firing
the kid probably like
five years ago when we're at fox and
then
stevo and i relate because right like he
came from this
kind of different path to stand up
different path
so then people talk [ __ ] about stevo
then they start including me
and then uh this comic
he was kind of well known and started
talking [ __ ] about stevo
and then someone was like yeah but
that's not always the case it was like
because
brendan chob and then they started
defending me and then the guy was like
we can't defend brennan
[ __ ] on stevo cause they're the same
like basically they came from different
paths
and had this built-in audience and then
started doing stand-up so then me and
siva always just had each other but also
stand-up's
not one of those things where it's like
you have to start at this age
you know it's not like fighting where
you have to start or like or anything
like
fighting's a bad example because you got
randy couture or you got guys who start
broccoli
later way later yeah oh well i mean you
know
but even starting to stand up later like
it's an advantage it's not even later
it's just
well but it's later than like i didn't
start like when it compared to faheem or
uh anawar
compared to dave chappelle when they're
16 or 14 where the [ __ ] it is
yeah you know so i started later but for
me at the advantage because i've
i've more life experience i have a
better thing a better perspective
yeah you know i started doing stand wise
19. you know what the [ __ ] going
through the [ __ ] i was talking about
early on i'm like what the [ __ ] i think
about it
what the hell was i talking about well
me and steve i probably talked to steve
at least once a month just yeah he's
just such a good dude yeah such a
genuine guy
yeah a lot just a really good dude yeah
he's hard to follow the comic store too
because his stand-up's different
it's not you know like bit bit bit bit
it's like a story
and he's so famous you know everyone
knows so he'll tell a story like him
dumping hot sauce in his eye but then it
goes comic comic comic
stevo comic and then comic comic comics
so it's like
it's just a different like energy it's
just a different rhythm
yeah okay no he was uh i had so much fun
with him that weekend
we did uh when i did 10 yeah he didn't
remember but not a big deal
yeah he definitely didn't of course he
definitely had many yeah i look
different
you do look different i don't have no i
i had a i usually cut my hair high and
tight
that's probably yeah that's why i didn't
i didn't uh
what i was running with you dude i was
going with you
hey look he could have thought it would
have been him
almost look the same let's not do that
you said it not me
did you guys watch the debates last
night hell yeah it was like
bruh did you guys watch it that was a
roasting session there must have been
40 to 50 million i don't do we know the
ratings bring up do we know the ratings
dude
it was like a super ball i was i had
anxiety i was nervous really
then they come out it was a [ __ ] show it
was just them like
interrupting each other you know like it
was fun nothing got accomplished like
let's say you're in the middle you're
like i don't know who i'm going to vote
for exactly you'd watch them like ah
what the [ __ ]
it was just them arguing 65 million
people watching is that a lot that's a
lot daughter
watch something that's insane dude
that's insane dog i never really looked
at joe biden
like looking at him last night i was
like yo you look at him you just
his face look like history like i was
like what the
like bro you shouldn't be in this i was
like bro how do i know
the bill of rights already just old
school [ __ ] too like trump was like
it was how about your son he's like my
son was a gold medal winning us no no
i saw that club the coke the one that
was doing all the cocaine that kicked
out
he was like he was going in the arms off
it's like damn he was going but he
called
the mediator it's like he's such a tough
job like you need to be
such an alpha male to be the mediator
because trump's just gonna [ __ ] take
control
yeah and so like what the guy so like
trump is such an alpha male the guy but
you only have two minutes and he would
just
steamroll through him like no no no no
i'm gonna re i'm i'm rebuttal what he's
talking about and just
i mean two minutes going for eight
minutes but trump like you have to be
such a kind of
almost really like alpha gangster where
you gotta like stand your ground but who
did they need who would be the great
like rogan would be great okay i saw him
trending but
not samuel jackson
after he would get destroyed i said two
minutes
you you need some like alpha male but
like no like you need someone you ain't
seen him in coach carter i don't know
what he was in he was i'm telling you
you need you need like an
alpha male who's not going to put up
with [ __ ] i saw the trump yeah
he sees the weakness and just steamrolls
you and he tried doing with biden then
buying him like kind of did low blows
too he's like come on
man yeah you're you're the worst
president that we've ever had like
he started going lowball i'm like ah
[ __ ] buy it and take the high road
dude like you're that yeah you can't you
can't take the high road with trump
though trump was getting them though
trump was digging to the bottom i don't
think anybody got
anybody was it's kind of like bit of a
[ __ ] show
well they were just interrupting each
other so like if you had if you went to
it wasn't productive no not at all like
if you went to watch the debates to get
like an honest opinion on
what their political like aspects are or
that what they believe in
you walked away just like like two
parents fighting
uh two gay older parents two gays
if you had two gay dads they were
arguing that's what it was
shout out to gay dads by the way yeah
doing the damn thing yeah
that you do but so they were just like
it was just
it was crazy it was just i loved it that
was the best entertainment
entertaining but yeah yeah politically
it was a [ __ ] show yeah damn
i think yeah i can't believe you guys
didn't watch it well i watched what are
you talking about
joe biden is a white walker for game of
thrones i see the face
you watch the cat uh no but people told
me it reminded them of like uh
love like love and hip hop reunion
yeah you killed 200 people
like where andy cohen comes in to like
interviews yeah you're talking about uh
but that's where the housewives oh how's
it going is a little more structured
exactly loving hip-hop is the water on
the people
come on back
all right let's do some current events
and wrap this up all right
wait is that what i want yes okay oh i
saw this video
there more so there was
this video it went viral because there's
this girl
who starts twerking in front of salt bay
and some man comes in
barging yelling at her and because this
clip went viral
there were people who looked into salt
bay's boston restaurant where he was at
and it got shut down for um like
breaking these coveted restrictions
because there were a bunch of people
online what a bunch of people weren't
wearing masks and stuff so in this video
shut down the rest don't go why do you
give a [ __ ] just don't go
mind your business this is a great twerk
by the way look at that twitter you're
doing that for salt bae hey look at her
man
oh man she ran
yo hold on nothing's
been confirmed i think she made like a
tick tock a few days after saying that
wasn't her boyfriend that wasn't her
friend
but a lot of people are speculating that
it was like her boyfriend like he took
her to dinner
i heard that from [ __ ] you doing that's
her man yeah that's so aggressive
something's going on so i'm going to
ain't a friend
i just
but also to get salt bait to film it
he's in the room there's too much
wheels in motion they're not
thinking that far she the way she tried
it off knows that she'd been through
like
a domestic violence because i heard this
restaurant in florida in miami is good
though
hurts really good look at that little
trout well she saw him oh let me get up
out here you see that
who who's the guy that did the elevator
thing ray rice
oh yeah the punch in the girl that's the
energy he had oh yeah same vibes
same vibes you feel it also air solange
and jay-z in the elevator
oh when salon was like gotta punk them
though huh she should be dead
cuz she was saying because yeah solange
is kind of hood
like beyonce is very classy and very
like
what's the worst elegant yeah elegant
like ladylike
yeah meanwhile solange will beat your
ass shalon's dated a [ __ ] that's why she
got all that energy oh she's doing it
she also has that ugly sister power i
don't even think about that the ugly
younger sister
ugly
it's just like you when they compared
your special to dave chappelle like you
said
why are you comparing her he's not my
brother though
if dave chappelle is my brother got a
point
got a point we have no relation you know
i don't open for him you know what i'm
saying like who's my brother
also jay-z but the other thing too jay-z
chin on beyonce
jay-z ugly as [ __ ] but he's jay-z
he's daisy that's joe campbell that's
joe campbell that is
[ __ ] you can do no wrong with you jay-z
solange is good i always say you know
yeah you're right she yeah she is good
what's this
so amazon just released that they're
gonna have new technology where you can
pay with just your hand
that's weird though because then you got
to put your because it's like yeah i
guess
they don't go into detail about how
they're going to do it exactly but it's
going to be like you swipe your hand i'm
guessing they're going to take like
almost like a fingerprint of your palm
and then you you insert your credit
card at the beginning so it has like
that information where
your palms id is then matched up to a
credit card and that's how you're
going in and out is it i mean it's cool
but it's definitely shady like what
is it why why why why why do we need
[ __ ] like that
man hold on brother i can't do it mm-hmm
and why my hand link to my food
check out clips you know yeah right for
hell no who's doing this whole foods
it might be because amazon does own
whole foods
they're going to try to sell this
technology whole foods
yeah are you fancy yeah no no that's i i
only go there for the meat for the meat
i like the pizza meat though but it's
better
yeah especially if i'm gonna cook it
yeah chef peel
what else you got all right um i want
you guys to look at this guy's picture
real quick first
all right oh okay so would you allow
this guy to be your kid's teacher
[ __ ] though so he was actually fired as
a kindergarten teacher
because one of the kids said that she
was getting nightmares from watching him
yeah however yeah what do you think's
gonna happen
he looked like that guy you know i think
he's actually able to teach
six and older so you still still
teaching but six and older not no longer
can i
just think like a kid's imagination like
when they see [ __ ] there was certain
[ __ ]
that would scare me as a kid like
paintings you know see that in that
teaching
that's not scary now i'm an adult ah
that's not good
his also his point of view is like he
likes the fact that he can look like
this
and then kids are around him so they
don't judge people by the way they look
as they grow up so that's what he says
here
except people from or who are different
from the norm maybe
they're adults they'll be little when
they're adults they'll be less racist
and less homophobic and more open-minded
homophobic i mean it's just overall how
someone i don't think he's good i think
he's just yeah
he's just in the world yeah it's just
tough man
i would be a little yeah i'd be a little
worried if i was a kid and i saw that
yeah i'd be terrible
there's just certain like stigmas like i
don't want my accountant having a neck
tattoo
we wouldn't trust them yeah trust them
yeah i would you would know some [ __ ]
use your bad sign imagine him coming in
school like hey today kids we're gonna
learn the louisiana purchase no we're
not
cover up cover up i don't know hell no
his eyes are tattooed guys there's
obviously some
i would assume mental issues too yeah no
that's not mental
do you tune your the whites of your
eyeballs let them live
well he can live just don't want to
teach him that's some stable
why would you touch that he might be a
great teacher i would just probably i'd
be like i'm just going to go
to another school yeah i just i wouldn't
feel comfortable leaving my kid
especially if it was a kindergartner
with this teacher it sucks
kids it sucks but i just can't imagine
do would you guys
know my kids in school right up the
street right now [ __ ] no no no
it's just the way i don't probably not
okay this is a good story
uh delante west so mark cuban
was looking for him i'm making phone
calls to find out where he was and
finally guys know about him right
yeah of course the guy who uh he smacked
on lebron james mom continue oh that's
the guy that did that
he [ __ ] lebron james bond no way we
don't talk yeah that that's why they had
issues then
then i don't know what lebron did dude
lebron got him off the lead shift
out of the league i believe he got him
out of society correct correct
so he ended up becoming homeless right
oh dante west and then
uh mark cuban actually went out to meet
him and met him at a gas station
and picked him up dropped him off at a
hotel where his mother was waiting to do
like you know an intervention
so now he's actually willing to go to
what do you call it uh therapy
rehab rehab rehab ready to go there
and i guess that's a good story right
mark cuban actually himself
drove up i love mark cuban on shark tank
i was just about to say that bro
come on bro he's so cool yeah the
coolest one is mark cuban and him
friends
or like how did that go well he was the
owner he played for that matter
okay he never played with lebron yes he
did he did that
all right i don't know the man's history
i just he had a video
he had a video remember he came out in
the video and all the nba players was
like man
we got to get them off the street and
they didn't do anything no no
mark cuban's like i got you yeah wow
yeah
i feel sad but but they're they're i'm
sure it says was he a really good player
solid he was like an all-star he was a
role player solid yeah i saw the role
player
he's just started in the nba don't smack
on the king's mom that's all we ask
don't [ __ ] lebron's mom is that yeah
wait wait wait what's wrong didn't she
want it nobody
did it i just said what does that have
to do with mom i have more of an issue
with my mom
yeah what does it have to do but you
don't see her at the games anymore you
remember she was all in the games like
you go baby
after that game not she can't [ __ ]
players they're in the bubble
no no no no this is years never years
ago you know really
yeah yeah so but here's the thing with
this done
what's his mom there have been players
you did that on of spite look at her
that's what he did it him at lebron
you get a picture of him in the mom
right there yeah right here no go to the
mvp mvp yeah
right there you did that you did that
out of spite
you did that out of spite that's real
that's real dog lebron james like okay
you have all these cleveland women and
you're gonna hit my mom
okay wow hell yeah what is but what over
here looking like carrot top
i mean i'd rather just not know i'm like
okay yeah do your [ __ ] thing leave me
no
that looks like that looks like carrot
topping the guy from green green mile
who the big black dude not not not duke
no yes oh god who passed away oh from
green mile
oh my god coffee john calvin that is
michael clark
i don't think that's his mom i think
this might be his girl because the other
pictures look like
this one's his mom right yeah that's his
mom in 1980s
what's the thing say though it just says
powell says homeless and hungry delonte
west is paranoid
we just click on this
checks into rehab jesus christ man i'm
pitching let's just see what this says
i don't know what this is
it's got to be his chick though okay
yeah that can't be lebron
go to lebron lebron and uh when he got
the mvp google lebron
right there right now we did delante
don't want to west no we don't want to
know
[Laughter]
type in lebron's mom that's his mama i
know but type in lebron
i don't know where you came from
look that's what he was hitting he did
that out of spite though you remember
she was all at the games
she was that like no look
i mean i see true i guess
i mean not bad wait go to the one where
she holding up lebron james sign
right to his face uh this one that right
there yeah that's cool
look you said that's not bad you said
that's not bad
you did it out of spite him and lebron
got into it he was like okay okay i'm
gonna shut up i'm gonna shut up it is
strange i wonder i don't
know how to be out of spite out of spite
no now look at young delante like he was
a handsome guy
yeah go to like a younger picture of him
look at that he could have pulled like a
like a snow bunny in cleveland come on
bro get him
and he wanted them light-skinned dudes
light-skinned dudes john b looking dude
john b
john b is white john duffy's white he's
not like
you're right well i would give him a
like we'll give him that he sounds black
on track
yeah on track he does not look like john
b
how dare you insult john b right yeah
that is true i apologize i did
how did we get on this oh cause you know
what's mark cuban
mark cuban yeah give us one more
all right let's see here let's pick a
good one
all right
let's go ahead chin gets
oh this is cool well it's not cool but
this dad
was in a car dealership and then some i
guess robbers came in and started
shooting
his kids were there on the couch and he
defended them like
jumped on top of them to make sure that
they weren't hit he got shot twice
and then because he works like
construction or whatever he got fired
because he couldn't do his job
jesus so then of course uh gofundme came
in it has
over like 200 something thousand dollars
for him yeah and he also saved his kids
too you want to see the video yeah uh
i want to see i want to say okay close
up mister why did this guy come shooting
i guess they're just robbing
[Music]
so he's just literally covering all of
his kids yeah
covering all of his when did they start
shooting again i think
i think there's one more that comes here
what they just went in there to shoot
i think they're robbing them probably
grab some money and get bounced i don't
know
don't look like too much yeah right it's
either oh another damn
is someone shooting back at them i'm
gonna guess who else had a gun in the
dealership
let's take a look at the story you said
you're selling cars that's where's that
at though
yeah we're that at oh it's uh bronx i
think bronx yeah
[Music]
damn damn it's up to
almost 300 grand now i mean this is
already an older
that's dope a few days so yeah that's a
great story
yeah but but there's not much details
probably doesn't want his name out there
who robs a dealership i mean
do they pay cash for some on some cars
no never there's no money
let's see where this gofundme is at
right now yeah almost three hundred
thousand three hundred thousand
like when does it stop though that's
what i was curious about like they have
a goal but when is this they have they
have a timeline of when the [ __ ] stops
okay well i can't i don't know you know
look i love how like mamie lord dee was
like yo
yo make sure they see i have a hundred
dollars
i'll give ahead i'm donating the other
one anonymous ninety nine dollars that's
what's up
he could have he could have went to a
hundred yeah he's gonna win that's kind
of petty a little bit 99.99 come on
okay it looks like like a gang thing
because three suspects fired multiple
shots and a male who then returned fire
so i might might have been just they
found out they were
shopping yeah for a car and they caught
him slipping
okay that makes sense that makes sense
way to discover chen
it wasn't on tmz we had to go the gun go
fund me damn that's crazy man what
dealership is that though i don't see
anything
yeah it looks like a ben yeah well i see
i see a lot of range rolls i just want a
honda civic it looks like a beam
i don't see any sensors on there well
it's weird because there's a mercedes
there's a bmw
used car use car a lot yeah that makes
it yeah maybe that's what a lot of drug
dealers shot
good for him getting 300k though payout
cash yeah
is that it i guess so all right man good
episode with steve oh man it's been fun
boys been dope
in the kids a lot of people have been
saying that a lot of them
but they said we're gonna get a z i was
just about to say the z right there
already it's actually how do you deliver
today we just added a z
oh i like that that's cool hollywood
hollywood okay uh see y'all in dallas
dallas
weekend saturday sold out yeah uh added
tickets to thursday
and friday show so get tickets now
tomorrow dallas let's ride
let's ride addison improv tpack.com for
tickets
phoenix tickets are on sale that is
november 5th through the 7th
nashville are on sale november 19th
through 21st get your tickets now
tfatkay.com uh i think that's it man
yup fellas thank you we're out yep